mais la situation des enfants prises au
piège dans ce conflit bonjour philippe
coric merci de venir sur notre plateau
directeur régional adjoint de l'unicef
en europe plus de la moitié du milieu et
demi du cognin échappant à la guerre
déclenchée sont les enfants ce sont des
chiffres qui sont quand même hallucinant
à mesure où le nombre de réfugiés
risquent encore de s'élever de passer à
4 millions oui c'est exact je l'amène
les ce conflit dans ce conflit les
enfants sont les premières victimes
7.5 millions d'enfants en ukraine sont
traumatisés par ce conflit certains sont
même tuer beaucoup sont blessés beaucoup
maintenant vous l'avez dit sont jetés
sur les routes de l'exode pour chercher
une protection avec leurs mamans leurs
grands parents dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles c'est plusieurs
jours de voitures des heures de marche
pour trouver un point de sécurité et je
pense tout particulièrement aussi aux
enfants avec handicap il ya 91 mille
enfants qui sont institutionnalisés en
ukraine dans la plupart d'entre eux sont
des enfants avec handicap donc ce sont
les plus vulnérables des plus
vulnérables sous les bombes dans leurs
institutions enfermés qu'ils ont été
séparés de leurs parents et qui sont les
plus vulnérables ce soir je voudrais
attirer l'attention également sur eux on
signale des écoles des orphelinats
bombardé qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire tout à fait et ça c'est
inacceptable le domaine vous avez des
écoles des maternités des orphelinats
des institutions de certains de ces
enfants avec handicap sont un type sont
institutionnalisés sont attaquées sont
détruites dont vous imaginez les
conditions d'horreur dans lesquels les
enfants sont subitement plongé et donc
il faut reconstituer à un univers de
protection l'unicef toujours travaillé
depuis 25 ans en ukraine nous avons un
réseau de partenaires avec les
municipalités les le ministère de la
santé le ministère de l'éducation avec
qui on avait on travaille depuis des
années et même dans le donbass l'unicef
travaille également pour les enfants
dans le donbass nous sommes
apolitique de travail vous avez arrêté
vos activités à kiev à kiev nous nous
continuons mais nous avons bougé notre
bureau de kiev et lviv quitte à 70
kilomètres de la pologne de la frontière
polonaise nous avons toutes les
opérations logistiques nous avons 150
personnes qui travaillent dans le pays
plus des équipes qui sont dans les pays
maintenant limitrophes pour accueillir
les réfugiés en exergue philippe corrie
massif on a parlé tout à l'heure de
risques de famine on parle maintenant
d'un début de polio alors la polio il
était déjà là on avait un comment dire
une épidémie qui commençait et nous
avions un plan il nous travaillons et
nous vaccinons toujours au jour
d'aujourd'hui l'unicef accident en
partenariat avec le gouvernement du cren
les enfants contre la polio donc c'est
et la rougeole qui est aussi un problème
et nous distribuerons de l'eau parce que
3,4 millions d'ukrainiens n'ont plus
accès à l'eau potable du fait que les
infrastructures sanitaires et
d'assainissement sont aussi ciblés et
sur les les pays accueillant les enfants
jetés sur les routes de l'exode en
arrivant en roumanie en moldavie en
pologne en hongrie en république tchèque
la réplique sovac nous mettons ce que
nous appelons des points bleus qui sont
des points services pour les familles la
première chose c'est le traitement du
traumatisme des enfants c'est essentiel
de le faire tout de suite et et comment
justement ce fait ce traitement cet
accueil sur le plan psychologique alors
les avants des psychologues qui sont
habitués à ce genre de situation et qui
crée des conditions de protection autour
de ce point bleu il ya des espaces
ludiques pour pour les enfants il ya
aussi bien sûr distributions d'eau de
nourriture également et de soins
d'hygiène parce qu'il faut des
couches-culottes imaginé trois jours de
voitures sans couches culottes avec des
bébés il faut des lingettes il faut donc
du matériel d'hygiène et de plus plus on
aura d'enfants sur les routes plus il
faudra s'occuper de cet aspect très
important l'unicef a lancé un appel aux
dons 400 millions d'euros de dette
demandé où est ce que ça en est qu'elle
avait foncé avance merci flammes et la
solidarité la première chose qu'il faut
c'est que tous les citoyens du monde
continuent à exprimer leur
horreur par rapport à
à ses enfants sous les bons et bien sûr
les dons permettent de faire avancer la
l'infrastructure de réponse humanitaire
l'unicef à toute une machine que nous
déployons immédiatement d'anglais dont
en france avec unicef.fr pour les
français et je voulais ici remerciés
déjà les français car les dons affluent
les gens sont choqués et la générosité
aussi c'est manifeste de toutes les
façons
philippe ory est ce que le sort fait aux
enfants peut-être déterminant dans cette
guerre ah oui tout à fait je pense que
plus le monde les opinions publiques
seront choqués avec ce qui se passe avec
la situation des enfants sous les bombes
en ukraine plus je pense que le monde
politique va va bouger merci beaucoup
philippe raud reid est revenu jusqu'à
notre directeur régional adjoint de
l'unicef en europe merci noter que à
travers le monde de nouveau